Local elections
yy during the past week
The leadership of the New Left
and the magician
Negotiating with the Citizens' Catalyst
A common start in elections
local governments
How are these conversations going?
have not yet begun on a leadership level
Because as you know
Prime Minister Donald Tusk
is busy now rightly and very well
Issues related to Ukraine
EE but
Such a meeting will probably take place in the coming days.
We will issue messages
But our structures are already preparing for these talks.
we are preparing some proposals
I think it would be a good thing
that the third way also participates in these conversations
and calls for it
No 3.
the road just says
that they go in their block I think
I think this is a mistake
that this is a mistake yy today is yy we co-create the government
Voters show it.
Surveys also expect cooperation.
Finding a common denominator
If we want to beat local governments
We should unite
strength and win more than fifty percent
because it will lead to this
that today the writing
will not be able to create in any
Most of them and that means
Specifically for the state
European money will go there.
The money will be
allocated yy
discretionary transparency available
with some tablets
which yy was printed to local governments
which were submissive to and solat
which have not yy been punished
that means concrete benefits for yy
inhabitants of cities and towns and villages
And I think that's what we should be playing tonight.
1 team to choose from
Exactly and this is not so
You just want these conversations.
Because no research
You could not have 1.
none provincial
You as a new Levine,
among other things
But what's wrong with that?
I mean,
that's why we do it.
so that we can all benefit from it
that no voice was wasted
Have you tried a civil coalition before?
Is there anything to talk about at all
Cause I hear yy
that in the regions of yy
platform politicians turn their noses to talk to you not
and I can just tell you
In these regions
which I have no dealings with
straight opposite
that many
Civil coalition politicians would like to cooperate
because he knows that together we will win more tickets
Just electoral calculation rewards these committees
which especially for the assemblies
that yy ym connect and cooperate with each other
You know what I'm afraid of
The third road will have to be saved.
As in the parliamentary elections
But there is no such threshold
The threshold is
but you know
that 15 real
real threshold of course 15
20% - OK.
but today the 3rd way has support of the order of 14
15%,
that's right.
We will have to save them.
probably once again
I'm afraid of that
that it will be as in the parliamentary elections
Where they had to
Many of our left-wing voters
The Civic Coalition
That's why I voted for the third way.
They had to be saved from disaster.
Thankfully,
this did not happen.
but here it can be similar
the real threshold you know that
the real threshold to the regional council is 15 20%
20 in Podkarpacie
Well,
that's why
There is law and justice,
as
It's like the 3rd way imagines There yy play these voices
I mean,
we really need to be leaders.
Today we take responsibility for Poland
These are not conversations about ambitions.
here we start together
and here separately
If we really want to win this election
local government and lead to this
that in Podkarpacie
yy in the Lublin region
or in others
regions the script will not be able to open the caliber
Every committee must
each without exception exceed at least 15
20% yy in this election
Will this happen in the case of the third road?
if he goes
Without a coalition and without the left.
I have doubts about that